a democratic secure and prosperous
georgia we will continue to work with
georgia
to promote the rule of law uh and
accountable institutions
okay under my uh what i wanted to start
with uh
egypt i and i know that you guys put a
readout of the secretary you put out a
readout of the secretary's call with the
foreign minister
but in that readout it talks about how
the secretary told the foreign minister
that human rights would be
central to the relationship the u.s
egypt relationship
and i'm just wondering if you can expand
on that what
what what is that actually uh what does
that mean
how does it manifest itself uh because
as you know
there was a bit of criticism just a week
ago
when you guys went ahead and approved
this
almost 200 million dollar sale of
missiles
uh to egypt in the midst of a crackdown
on
uh dissidents matt what i would say
is to reiterate something that president
biden first said on the campaign trail i
believe it was in october of this year
he made the point
uh and it's a point that applies to
his now administration that human rights
uh our values principles
that are universal
will always be we will always carry them
with us
in our bilateral relationships that
includes importantly
when it comes to our closest security
partners
we have of course discussed some of them
in this briefing room
the idea that relationships can be
multifaceted
we have interests but we of course have
our values we're never going to discount
our values
in pursuit of our interests and that is
true
in the case of egypt the president and
the secretary they've been clear
that democracy and human rights must be
at the forefront of u.s foreign policy
the state department consistently
discusses with the government of egypt
our concerns over lack of respect for
human rights including
freedom of expression and freedom of
association we spoke
last week multiple occasions about the
detention
of the family members of muhammad sultan
um
[Music]
so clearly these issues will always be
in
our bilateral or bilateral relationship
you saw that reflected in the readout
today
but i guess my my question is does that
does that manifest itself in anything
in the short term that in terms of an
actual
policy decision or is it just telling
the egyptians that you're not happy
happy about how they're how they're
handling it
what is the what is the tangible result
of human rights being central to the
relationship well the tangible result
is taking place every day here at
maine state um and also in our embassy
in cairo but also in embassies
around the world our state department
officials
are raising these issues they are
supporting
human rights defenders we talked about
12 of them in the context of
the anti-corruption awards awardees that
we announced uh today
um and we can talk about it in the
context of egypt the fact that it was
raised
in this uh the secretary's first call
with his egyptian counterpart
i think speaks to the priority we attach
to this issue
uh of course matt you will probably be
the first to remind me that uh
words are no substitute for deeds and so
uh you can see those deeds well you
would see those deeds um if you could
see the work
uh on the part of what is going on in
our embassy uh in cairo
uh what's going on here first of all i'm
happy to take you know i'll i'll
i just want to know if there was any if
there's anything like in the immediate
term after this call
and him saying that it's going to be
central if there's any
shift any anything
substantive that we can actually see
other than
other than just the readout certainly i
hope
what we see um is
uh what happens on the part of the
egyptian government that's where we want
to see improvement
um that is where uh we are we are making
this point to them
thanks uh great yes please sure
i was wondering um what you guys have to
say about the
report of the iaea um
saying that they are deeply concerned
about the possible presence of
uh nuclear material at an undeclared
site in iran
and also of course on the decision today
to
go forward with the restricting the the
access for the inspectors despite
everything that happened last weekend
well we talked about this a little bit
yesterday but we
we have in fact seen the iaea's latest
quarterly report on iran
um it remains restricted uh until the
board decides uh it can be released
publicly
um we fully support as i said yesterday
the director general's
efforts to ensure full implementation of
iaea verification in iran
and we have full faith and confidence in
the director general
and the iaea more broadly
we wouldn't comment on the details of
this report
until it's released publicly um but what
we can say is that
and it's certainly no secret is that
iran continues to take steps
in excess of its jcpoa limits uh iran
has also recently taken steps
uh to reduce cooperation uh with the
iaea including
the additional protocol you heard the
director general speak to this
over the weekend you heard me speak to
this yesterday
as well we have underscored our concern
that iran
is moving in the wrong direction it is
moving further away from
its nuclear constraints uh our objective
uh in all of this uh remains to seek an
outcome in which iran
and the united states resume compliance
with their commitments under the jcpoa
these steps by iran the steps that um
we have spoken to the that the iranians
have spoken to publicly
are clearly moving in the wrong
direction we also know that the iaa
continues to
investigate a number of serious
outstanding issues
related to potential undeclared nuclear
material in iran
to to your question we insist
that iran cooperate with the iaea to
resolve these issues without further
delay
um we'll be in close consultation with
the iaea board of governors
to discuss appropriate action in support
of
the agency's efforts um and all the
while
um we have made clear that uh the the
best the most sustainable the most
effective
way to place limits uh
verifiable and permanent limits on
iran's nuclear program
is through a negotiated solution to this
uh the proposition that the president
has put has put on the table
has been known for quite some time now
even before he was president united
states
the shorthand being compliance for
compliance if iran
resumes its full compliance with the
nuclear deal the united states will be
prepared
to do the same that is a necessary
but not sufficient step uh it's not
sufficient because we
from there would like to lengthen and
strengthen the deal we would like to
negotiate
follow-on agreements to address other
areas of iran's malign uh
influence including its ballistic
missile program uh the first step in all
of this a natural outgrowth from what we
have been saying for some time
is to meet uh with the iranians under
the auspices of
the p5 plus one i don't have an update
for you there obviously we
made our offer known last week we did
that in tandem with
our european partners i've made this
point before but
there has been a lot of ink spilled and
attention paid to
the offer that we put forward i think in
in many ways what was
more noteworthy um was the joint
statement that emanated from the e3
uh and the secretary of state uh
secretary blinken
it was a clear signal that after weeks
of consultations weeks of coordination
uh with our european allies our closest
allies we are now on the same page
we are walking in lockstep with them
down this path of diplomacy
it is no longer we are no longer working
at cross purposes uh we are working hand
in glove
with our european allies uh and we
believe that gives us
a position of strength um when it comes
to these negotiations and and we believe
it provides the best
uh path forward yes thank you
i want to change topics if it's okay
with my colleagues anything else on a
run quickly
uh sure we'll take uh rosalind and then
we'll
uh thanks ned uh congressional
republicans had criticized the jcpoa one
because
it should have been a treaty in their
view and
now they're trying to put pressure on
the administration to not
give in to iran's repeated demands to
lift the sanctions that were imposed by
the previous administration
saying the u.s should not be in the
business of rewarding bad behavior
in the past couple of hours connecticut
senator chris murphy when asked
said that he doesn't think it would be
necessarily a bad idea
to remove those sanctions in order to
get the us
and iran talking again
is this a topic of discussion between
the administration and members of
congress to perhaps get some political
cover
to consider at least lifting some of the
sanctions
to get this process moving is this
simply a red line and i use that term
as a term of art that the administration
isn't going to do
that iran has to come back into
compliance
no ifs ands or bots well rosalind i
would start by making the point
that iran moved away started to move
away
from its constraints under the jcpoa
after the may 2018 decision
uh to leave the jcpoa
um i when the agreement was
adhered to by all sides um it was
working it was working according to the
iaea
it was working according to this
building it was working according to
the intelligence community um as well as
according to our international
partners um that is why we continue to
believe that the i
that the jcpoa uh forms an appropriate
basis
uh to uh start to um hold those
discussions to lengthen and strengthen
the deal
that of course was uh concluded in 2015
um and to to build on it uh now when it
comes to the consultations you
referenced
um what we have said really since
january 20th
is that the first step in this process
is to undertake consultations
with our allies and i've spoken to the
e3
uh in this context with our partners and
of course there were
there are other members of the p5 plus
one of course who are not treaty allies
um there are other interested parties uh
around the world uh including our
partners
uh in the region uh and with members of
congress and
uh those consultations with members of
congress have been
uh ongoing uh we want to make sure that
uh well i should say that that we know
uh that our approach
um will have the most legitimacy um and
prospects for success uh when we have
that support not only from our partners
and allies
but from key members uh of congress when
it comes to
the proposals that have been put on the
table uh our
return here is quite simple we offered
last week
to meet with the iranians we said we'd
be willing to meet with the iranians in
the context of
the p5 plus one because that's where we
believe
these issues are best discussed and
adjudicated um
there's been posturing uh in tehran
there has been
posturing elsewhere i we think that
discussions negotiations
um engaging in that clear-eyed
principled diplomacy
together with our closest partners the
e3 in this case along with the other p5
plus one members
that's the place where we want to have
those discussions
the south korean foreign ministry said
today that uh it has reached an
agreement
in principle with the iranians to
unfreeze some of the
uh oil uh money that's been frozen by
u.s sanctions
but that it's pending uh u.s approval is
that the case and are you involved in
discussions with the south koreans to
unfreeze that money well we don't have a
comment precisely on that
uh precisely because uh there has been
no
transfer of funds as as you alluded to
um we wouldn't want to comment on
uh bilateral negotiations with other
countries
um you've heard me speak to uh our close
consultations
uh with allies and partners and of
course
uh the south koreans are public of korea
um
a key ally um a key treaty ally um
and uh very much a partner um when it
comes to sanctions enforcement
uh across the board uh so it wouldn't be
a surprise
um it wouldn't come as a shock i'm sure
to hear you say that uh we do discuss
these issues broadly um with the south
koreans but i wouldn't want to
characterize it beyond that
anything else on a run are we ready to
move on one more yeah
sort of iran former secretary of state
well it's a mike
it's it's a it's it's a mike pompeo iran
question
former secretary of state pompeo was on
fox news today
and uh said that um current biden
administration officials uh during the
trump years had sought to
undermine trump's iran policy and called
it
uh un-american uh including
communications that uh fox news said
that they had with foreign minister
zarif and i wondered if he wanted to
respond to former secretary pompeo that
fox news said they had with
they reported sorry i didn't understand
reported on some of these i think were
previously known
uh interactions with foreign minister
zarif that occurred during the trump
administration uh secretary former
secretary pompeo was asked about them
today on fox
said that uh those people had been
trying to undermine uh trump policy and
called it un-american and i wondered if
you want to respond to that
i don't want to respond to that directly
um what i what i would say
is that uh everyone in this
administration
shares the view of the president united
states that iran
cannot be allowed to acquire a nuclear
weapon i wouldn't want to speak for the
previous administration
uh but i would hazard a guess that they
believed the same believed the same i
should say that iran
should never be allowed to acquire a
nuclear weapon it is also no secret
that uh this president and this
administration
uh have uh and key principles had
profound disagreements
uh with the way in which the previous
administration
sought to bring that about um even in
this briefing uh you have heard
me say that while the jcpoa was
in effect while it was still in effect
of course but while all sides were
in full compliance um iran was living up
to its commitments
and that is not my opinion that was the
assessment of this building
part of the iaea and we say when we say
that iran was living up to its
commitment
the commitment that iran had when it was
in full compliance and full performance
of its jcpoa
requirements uh was uh strict
limit limitations uh on its nuclear
activities
uh a strict verification and monitoring
regime in fact the strictest ever
negotiated uh and a prohibition
um indefinite permanent prohibition
on iran's acquisition of a nuclear
weapon
that is why this administration
continues to believe
uh that the jcpoa forms an appropriate
basis
to begin broader discussions uh to begin
broader discussions
for lengthening and strengthening the
deal and then of course as i said before
negotiating follow-on agreements
uh there this has
always been a this has been a
contentious issue um but i think
every good faith actor um can come to
this issue
um in this country believing that um
american interests should always be put
first uh that iran should never be
uh allowed to acquire a nuclear weapon
and we believe the best way to do that
is through principled
uh clear-eyed diplomacy
was that even if iran was complying in
full compliance
the the agreement the deal was so flawed
that it would still give them a pathway
uh to develop
a bomb because of the sunset clauses
because of the
uh the end of
the end of certain uh sanctions that uh
some of which began in in september
which you guys have withdrawn the
snapback so
i mean can you can you at least
acknowledge there's a fundamental
difference in the
in and how this administration views it
and how
the previous administration viewed i
mean they thought the previous
administration's argument was that
even if iran completely complies
it's still a bad deal because they can
still
enrich the the limit on in enrichment
the
limits on centrifuges and everything get
get get
lifted over a period of time uh mata a
couple things
were undeniably true um and i say that
with the caveat that
it's of course no secret uh that the
previous administration
um appeared to have a very different
view
of the utility um uh the general utility
of the jcpoa but a couple things
uh were true before the jcpoa went into
effect uh
iran's breakout time the time it would
need to develop enough missile material
for a nuclear weapon
uh was estimated uh in a handful of
months
when iran was in full compliance and
full performance of its jcpoa
commitments
that time went up to a full year
also iran is permanently barred
from obtaining a nuclear weapon but that
permanent bar
okay that that you're talking about the
fatwa
no i'm not talking about the fatwa i'm
talking about the nonproliferation
treaty
well so there is a permanent they just
suspended their cooperation
but the additional protocol is separate
from the npc but
i okay so okay sounds like i've answered
the question yes
okay thank you all right uh i have a
couple questions if you would indulge me
on the palestinian issue
uh first on secretary lincoln's
conversation yesterday
phone call with his counterpart the
israeli ashkenazi
and he emphasized that the body
administration adheres
to the two-state solution could you tell
us
where does this administration envision
this two-state solution
to be and is east jerusalem part of it
well um i would say that uh the
secretary
um was pleased to speak with his israeli
counterpart they've had
um multiple conversations uh at this
uh at this point uh we've said before
the united states remains unwavering
in our commitment to israel's security
and will work to strengthen
all aspects of the israeli
bilateral bilateral relationship
when it comes to uh the two-state
solution
the biden administration believes
that the two-state solution is the best
way to
ensure israel's identity
as a jewish and democratic state uh
while living uh in peace alongside a
viable
and democratic palestinian state uh that
is precisely why
uh the two-state solution continues uh
to be
the crux of how we view
the conflict and where we believe and
how we believe
the conflict should be resolved now of
course
[Music]
i don't think anyone is saying that a
negotiated
two-state solution um is in the offing
in the coming hours or days
um we are realistic but at the same time
we believe it provides a durable
framework for the in-state uh that we've
talked about
you know so much has changed i mean do
you feel that you have leverage with the
the current israeli the prime minister
who's you know running for
re-election very very soon you know i
mean is it is it really worthwhile to
speak with him about
not taking unilateral actions i mean do
you see him
to be aminable to whatever
issues that you raise with them on well
i think i think this goes back to
the issue i was speaking to before uh
that
the united states uh we're the world's
uh strongest most powerful country we
can uh pursue and accomplish multiple
things at once
uh we have interests and we have values
uh those things need not be inconsistent
uh and in fact
uh our interests are our values uh and
and vice versa
uh so when it comes to the two-state
solution
uh our values are at play on on both
sides uh frankly
um we believe uh israel um should
continue to be
a jewish and democratic uh state at the
same time
uh we believe that the palestinians
deserve uh their
uh legitimate aspirations for
statehood and independence so we bring
our values with us
in every relationship across the board
we talked about in egypt
we've talked about in other countries in
this room and it's certainly true when
it comes to
israel as well right you know just if
you indulge me just a little bit
uh you know but this prime minister has
had a tradition
during every elections almost every year
where he would take
unilateral action to satisfy a very you
know very fundamentalist base and so on
the settlers i mean let's be open and so
on if he takes such actions are you
are you telling him not to at all and
will there be consequences if he did
i think and and i may have said this in
response to one of your previous
questions
uh but we have been very clear from
this room and uh and and uh more broadly
uh we believe it is critical um for
uh israel to refrain from unilateral
steps
that exacerbate tensions and undercut
those efforts to advance a two-state
solution
again we believe in the centrality and
the premise of a two-state solution we
don't want to see
um either side uh take a step that would
put that further out of reach
uncovered see just just one last thing
on uncovered
i i know that uh my colleague from
horace asked you last week
and he suggested that these raiders are
allowing 100 000
vaccines to to go in you know but until
today really nothing has happened
are you following up on that i mean the
israelis seem to be withholding as a
matter of fact preventing
these vaccines from going to gaza going
to the west bank and so on what is your
position on this and
especially with the world bank report
yesterday saying that
the situation is really quite disastrous
there and it needs to be
quick remedy well we believe it's
important uh for
palestinians to achieve increased access
to covid vaccine uh in the weeks ahead
i think i talked about this i guess it
was on friday um
we believe it's important um for their
own
for their own needs it's important for
israel israel's health and security as
well
but there's also a broader dynamic at
play as long as kovid
is uh uncontrolled um in any part of the
world
we can see the development of these
variants that have posed such
a challenge to us um that is why this
administration has undertaken
uh a uh an effort to uh distribute a
safe and effective vaccine
uh to millions of americans millions of
americans
um per day uh and some days uh and it is
also why uh we have made commitments on
the international stage
uh through gavi uh the two billion
dollar commitment the president
announced
uh uh late last week uh followed by a
longer term
additional two billion dollars um that
near term two billion dollars is
uh we have prioritized it precisely
because
um we know that no american can
ultimately
be safe or that this country cannot
ultimately be safe from covet
while it continues uh to run in the wild
and uh the more people we can vaccinate
of course in this country
but the more people who are also
vaccinated around the world uh the
quicker
we can squash this pandemic and protect
americans
uh here at home rich ned
you released earlier today a readout
regarding the secretary's call with the
polish foreign minister
uh the foreign minister wrote that he uh
and his ukrainian counterpart were
calling on the biden administration to
use all means at their disposal
to prevent nordstrom 2 from happening um
do you agree that this administration
or will this administration agree that
uh you guys are on the same page that
you're using all at your disposal to
stop nordstrom ii
well rich uh i think we talked about
this a little bit yesterday but
um in the first weeks of this
administration
uh we conducted uh the assessment that
we submitted to congress on friday
um and importantly to your question we
consulted closely uh with our
european uh partners and our european uh
allies
i think it is fair to say that um none
of our partners our allies would have
been taken by surprise
um by uh what ultimately uh was in
that assessment um when it comes to um
uh the polls we certainly uh share
their concerns uh with uh nordstrom 2
uh more broadly that is why we have been
unequivocal uh in saying that
nordstrom 2 is a bad deal it is a bad
deal for europe
um it is a bad deal uh for europe's uh
in the context of europe's own
stated energy goals uh so this is not
what we submitted on friday was not the
end of the story um it was
a report that congress uh required
congress obviously has a legitimate
interest in this we will continue to
keep congress apprised
and if additional policy responses are
warranted
to fulfill legislative requirements
or to fulfill our interests when it
comes to nordstrom 2.
we won't hesitate to do that as part of
your consultations a bipartisan group of
lawmakers sent a letter last week they
used open source
data to identify ships that were working
on
that uh project uh they say they've not
gotten a response is the state
department looking into that the charges
in that letter and and can they expect a
response
uh so i'll i'll uh i'm not familiar with
a letter i'll let you know if we have
anything specific uh to
say on that but um of course in the
report that we submitted to congress
last friday and that we spoke to
uh yesterday we did identify uh the
russia-based kbt
roofs um as an entity knowingly
selling leasing or providing the vessel
for tuna
in the construction of the pipeline
we determined that kvt roost was
partaking in sanctionable activity
precisely because it was engaged in
pipelining or pipelining activities at
depths of a hundred
feet or more which i understand to be
the key criterion uh when it comes to
pisa
the the legislation at play here uh so
the as i said before the report on
friday was not the end of the story
it was just the latest chapter we will
continue to monitor to evaluate and if
additional policy responses
uh are warranted we won't uh hesitate to
take themselves
myanmar you've talked a lot about
trying to get allies and especially
allies in the region
to pressure the burmese military to
change course
um there's an initiative by indonesia
and
an asean initiative led by indonesia
which is trying to push the burmese
military to
stick by their promise of holding
elections in a year and
apparently a trip planned by the
indonesian foreign minister which would
be the first
sort of engagement with the new um
military hunter
does that does the us sort of have a
position on this because it seems it
seems
uh contradictory of your position which
has been to try and get the
the hunter to turn the generals to sort
of um
change course rather than saying yes you
can take power for a year as long as you
hold elections after a year so that
you know it seems to be out of whack
there well i understand that proposal
uh remains hypothetical and so we
wouldn't want to
weigh in on this at this stage uh
what i would say and i would reiterate
something we have said
ever since uh the coup on february 1st
uh something we determined to be a coup
uh the very next day and we've been
unambiguous
about ever since um burmese
burma's military leaders uh must see
that their attempts to replace
burma's democratically elected uh
government
um and its violent actions will have
consequences
uh of course last night uh we announced
uh
uh
an additional uh set of uh sanctions uh
there was a g7 statement that i'm sure
you saw
uh this morning again the united states
and our uh
some of our closest partners uh and
allies uh speaking with one voice
uh condemning uh what's going on and of
course we're not the only country
taking action uh to promote
accountability for
the military leaders behind uh this coup
uh in fact we applauded the recent
sanctions uh that sanctions
announcements that were made by
uk uh and canada um as well as the
announcement that the eu
will look into its own uh its own
measures uh so our message
to the junta um has not changed
they must relinquish power they must
restore uh
the democratically elected uh government
and our
message to the people of burma has not
changed uh we stand with the people of
burma
uh we will continue again uh in concert
with our like-minded allies and partners
around the world
um to support uh their um
aspirations uh for the restoration of a
civilian-led government uh in burma
sure thank you um have the united states
receive full moon requests from the
burmese diplomats in the united states
who are asking uh for asylum because
they do not want to side
with the military leaders they want they
don't want to go back home to
they want to be on the same side with
the burmese people
and separately how would you
characterize the
hard other members in the cross position
regarding
the sanctions um i was reading the
the statement after the court meeting um
they called for a return for democracy
palace no measure on the sanctions
are lay on the same page with the u.s in
regards to
sanctions with uh against the military
leaders thank you
well you saw from the readout that uh
was issued after that meeting
uh late last week i suppose it was that
there is unanimity uh
in the position that uh democracy uh
that civilian leadership
must be restored uh to the people of
burma we've heard that from the quad
uh we've heard that from the g7 uh we've
heard it heard it from
other countries individually other
constellations of of countries together
um now we've heard it from the u.n
security council uh
so the world is speaking with just about
one voice uh when it comes to
um uh opposing the military coup in
burma
and supporting uh the aspirations of uh
the people of burma to restore
their civilian democratically elected
government the united states will
continue to
offer that rhetorical support but also
to take action
in furtherance of those goals as i
mentioned before we announced two
additional
uh sanctions against two of uh
additional um
members of the military uh some of our
close allies and partners
um have announced their own sanctions or
their intent
uh to sanction um uh as i
said in a very different context uh when
it comes to united states it's certainly
not the end of the story
um and we will continue uh to pursue
means
um uh on a policy basis uh to fulfill
our goal um to support the burmese
people uh and to restore
uh democratic and civilian rule um
uh in burma when it comes to burmese if
not the united states we'll see if we
can get you um anything uh on that front
can we can i please ask about georgia's
political crisis
um thank you for lorita on the top of
the briefing
um have the united states or
the embassy or state department have any
communication
with the current prime minister over the
detention of the
opposition leader and in your assessment
what would happen next are sanctions
in the u.s toolbox thank you well
uh as i said we we urge uh the
government of georgia to act in line
uh with its own aspirations with its own
euro atlantic aspirations and to
reinforce uh its commitment to
uh democracy individual liberty uh and
the rule of law
by ensuring that its judicial and
prosecutorial system is free
of uh political bias we have made uh no
bones uh about where we stand
uh the fact that i am saying this from
uh the podium is certainly a good
indication
uh that we have had um more candid uh
discussions
uh with our interlocutors uh including
interlocutors
uh in georgia um again not to be
repetitive but this goes back to what
we've said several times throughout this
briefing about the united states
um always having uh our values taking
our values in hand
when we enter into bilateral
relationships or in multilateral flora
clearly there are values we hold dear
at play here liberty rule of law
prosecutorial system
uh that is independent and free of
political
influence uganda sorry i'm sorry
about uganda uganda yes um
yes please um does did you just do the
arrests in the united states view
uh threaten georgia's nato aspirations
uh look the what we've seen in recent
days
is in contravention of georgia's own
euro-atlantic aspirations
uh i wouldn't want to um uh go beyond
that um what i will say is i'll be
watching closely
uh in the hours and and days ahead uh
we've made no secret
about what we believe uh believe needs
to happen
uh with georgia uh and we'll see if
that's the case uh uganda
yes um so opposition leader bobby wine
said on sunday like he was dropping the
legal challenge to
uganda's presidential election resort
that handed the victory to incumbent um
mustafani
uh citing supreme court justice hearing
the case were
biased can the state department comment
on the latest
development and does the u.s consider
muslim failure as a reliable partner in
the war against terror
well i believe we said this before but
it probably bears reiterating that
uganda's january 14th elections
were marred by election irregularities
and abuses by the government's
security services against opposition
candidates and members of civil society
we strongly urge independent credible
impartial and thorough investigations
into these incidents we'll consider a
range
of targeted options to hold accountable
those members of the security forces
responsible um for these actions when it
comes to
president museveni uganda of course
does continue to play a regional role um
and does have
um an important role when it comes to
some of our uh
interests uh in the region um it is a
troop contributing country to amisom uh
in somalia
um in its international efforts to
defeat al-shabab but
again um this goes to the point that
we've now made uh
even more times throughout this briefing
that um we can
pursue our interests uh and pursue our
values at the same time
um uh we are considering as i said a
range of targeted options to hold
accountable
uh those who are responsible for uh what
we saw in the context of
uh uganda's uh elections um just as
um uh we continue uh to
work um with uh uh
uganda um to pursue uh some of our
mutual interests
uh we'll take a final final question or
two uh
let's let's try and move around a little
bit yes
i wanted to ask you about the maiden's
administration had said over and over
that it wanted to see an end to the war
in yemen
what steps if any is the us
administration taken at this point
and if i can bring in iran into this
conversation
as the u.s is trying to get iran to the
negotiating table how do you
what role do you envision around playing
in yemen at this point
well when it speaking to the steps that
we have taken to
prioritize an end to the war in yemen
first um the president united states
made very clear
uh in his visit here i guess it was a
few weeks ago now last month
that we would prioritize and throw our
energy behind
a diplomatic solution working closely
with the u.n envoy martin griffis
that same day he appointed a career
foreign service officer tim linderking
to be our special envoy
for yemen the fact that this
administration named
a special envoy someone uh with the
respect both in this building and
capitals around the world
uh to take on uh this work full-time i
think speaks to that prioritization when
it comes to tim linderking
we mentioned yesterday that he is now
back uh in the gulf
uh he is currently um uh meeting with
uh interlocutors uh in the region this
comes just a week or so after his first
trip
uh to the region he went to saudi arabia
uh shortly after
he was named he met with martin
griffiths he met
he met with representatives of the
government of yemen our saudi
interlocutors as well
so he has been hard at work in this
building
and in the region uh already in an
effort to
uh seek to push forward uh that goal
of a uh political solution um
to this conflict in yemen yemen which is
now home to the world's worst
humanitarian catastrophe
speaking of that humanitarian
catastrophe um
we look forward to participating in the
unhigh level pledging event
on the humanitarian crisis in yemen on
march 1st which i believe
is next monday it's an event that's
co-hosted by switzerland and sweden
march 1st it is next month
according to the calendar i believe it
is monday because it is
it is monday um uh as i said uh the
humanitarian crisis in yemen uh it is
home to the world's worst humanitarian
crisis
uh and we are seeking to raise the
ambition uh not only in this country but
um from uh on the part of our partners
too when it comes to
what they uh are willing to contribute
and able to contribute
uh to bring an end to the humanitarian
plight of the many people i saw one
one final question there yeah yes thank
you uh if i could uh two
uh china questions the uh there's been
some speculation about who the
ambassador
would be for uh for beijing and i know
you can't drop hints
from the podium but could you give us a
sense of the uh the timing
for when we will see the nominees put
forward
and also can you give us any sense of
what are the
uh what are the attributes or skill sets
that
the biden administration is looking for
when secretary blink is looking for
given the very contentious nature of the
uh the bilateral relationship the other
question is just regarding the
upcoming bilateral between president
biden and
prime minister trudeau the canadian
house of commons voted to declare that
china is committing
uh genocide against the uyghurs but uh
prime minister trudeau and his cabinet
abstains from that
so the position of the biden
administration as we know is that these
these activities do constitute genocide
so i wanted to get a sense of
what uh what the biden administration
what secretary of lincoln
proposed to do to get the two sides on
the same page on this issue
uh so on your first question as you know
ambassadoral nominations are the
prerogative of the president uh and so
i'm not in a position to
offer any sense of timeline uh and
certainly not the identity of of who
might ultimately end up representing our
interests uh in beijing i think what we
do know however
uh is that uh our ambassador
uh will be responsible for helping to
steward
uh an approach to china that has
competition
uh at the center we know that uh this is
a relationship that has adversarial
elements
it has competitive elements and the
competitive elements uh are really at
the crux of that relationship it also
has
a a number of cooperative elements and
we've talked about
uh the fact that when it is in our
national interest in america's national
interest
uh that there can be times when uh
cooperation will be on the table climate
for example
um is is one of those um uh areas so
uh whoever ends up in beijing will have
a lot on her his plate
um uh and the president will want to
make sure that that person
um uh uh is appropriately empowered and
and uh sees eyes to eye see i sees eye
to eye
with the president uh on the best
approach to compete and ultimately to
out-compete
um with uh china on the issues uh
that are near and dear uh to us
um on on genocide um
we've been very clear that uh secretary
blinken uh has determined
uh that uh what has taken place in
xinjiang
uh was genocide we've also been very
clear that it constitutes
crimes against humanity um
obviously other governments are looking
very closely at this
there are different processes within
different capitals i wouldn't want to
speak to any other government's efforts
to
define or even to evaluate
what has gone on but i will say that we
have
prioritized an approach to china
that in the first instance um
seeks to ensure that we are competing
with and out competing
uh with china from a position of
strength uh and there are a number of
sources of strength uh our values uh are
a source of strength
our alliances and partnerships are a
source of strength and it's relevant to
your question
uh when we seek to take on china alone
as
we've done in the past i think that
the results would be meager compared to
what we can do
um when we are galvanizing collective
action when we are bringing
uh our european allies our allies and
partners in the indo-pacific
uh along with us and that is in uh
essentially every realm the security
realm
i uh when it comes to human rights
abuses
um as you mentioned and so that's
precisely uh what we
are trying uh to do i'm sure we'll be
speaking a lot more
about uh the ways in which we will seek
uh to bring those partners along
not only to highlight uh the abuses
and the outrages that have taken place
uh in places like xinjiang
but ways to seek to change behavior on
the part of
beijing seek to change that underlying
conduct
technical question on what you just said
that you said secretary blinken has
determined that what's taking place in
jinjang is a genocide does that mean
that since
in the last 30 days this administration
has undertaken a separate
a new review that's different from the
one that the previous administration
took because
you know secretary pompeo had determined
that it was a genocide as well and
and secretary blinken and or then
designate uh what said that he agreed
with that determination
but has there been has this
administration made its own
new determination separate from the
previous administration
so this building this building along
with our interagency partners we are
constantly evaluating
uh all sources of information when it
comes to what's going on in xinjiang on
a human rights basis or anywhere else
i i our bureau of east asian pacific
affairs
our bureau of global criminal justice uh
our uh
office of the legal advisor um inr a
number of other entities are constantly
looking
uh at those inputs um but uh secretary
blinken has been very clear and he has
the prerogative to say this
uh what uh has taken place in xinjiang
constitutes genocide i don't know if
there was a
separate new determination by this
administration
since january 20th that is a genocide or
or if you're just agreeing with the
previous administrations which is
secretary secretary blinken came to that
conclusion
on the basis of uh the information he
was receiving
uh as a close adviser to the
president-elect prior to
becoming well he he he mentioned in his
confirmation hearing which took place
prior to january 20th
um but we are constantly evaluating uh
and reviewing uh what is going on so
that
uh we can shine a spotlight on human
rights abuses and ultimately uh hold to
account those who would perpetrate them
thank you very much uh we'll do it again
tomorrow